according to elon  his new school in texas will be called  the texas institute of technology and  science the acronym of course spells  tits and unfortunately elon school has  become a very unsafe place already for  feminists  this week in feminism  [Music]  so yeah no i was just walking to class  oh my god a penis  [Music]  did joe biden poop himself is the next  story  i'm betting yes how did elon miss that  tits yeah no there's no way of course he  did it i feel like he did it as a joke  yeah that's but that's like several  billion dollar joke well i mean he can  afford to make it into the government i  guess i wanted to be a school for  engineering and it will be called the  texas institute of technology and  science  i got my phd in tits